hip-hop producer jamal rasheed also
known as mali maul
is headed to prison rasheed admits he
was a long-time pimp
and profited off of women that he abused
and it's a story the i-team has been
following
george knapp first broke how there was
an fbi investigation into alleged
corruption at metro's vice unit
sheriff joe lombardo insisting the unit
has been cleaned up
no officers were charged it appears
rasheed's case is the only one to move
forward
as a result of that investigation while
no cameras are allowed inside federal
court the i-team's vanessa murphy
was the only tv reporter in town to
watch what unfolded today
she has more jamal rashid also known as
mali maul
declined to give us a comment as he
walked in and out of this federal
courthouse in downtown las vegas
he is now sentenced to 33 months in
prison
prosecutors say he worked as a pimp a
judge called him
a monster in the past jamal rashid who
has worked in music with
artists like justin bieber drake and
many others
abused and manipulated women for years
according to prosecutors
they say he prostituted hundreds of
women from 2002 to 2014 in las vegas
and victims discussed threats of
surveillance verbal abuse
and actual violence rasheed operated
escort businesses which were just
fronts for prostitution he advertised on
websites flew women to different
locations to sell sex
and had rules for them judge gloria
navarro says his victims went through a
form of imprisonment
i have faith that you know his
expiration date is coming up soon
angela williams told the i-team in 2019
she is one of rasheed's victims
she now says she is pleased with
thursday's outcome
rasheed said in court he is sorry i
heard you apologize in the courtroom is
there anything you want to say to the
victims on camera right now
we have no comment at this time we did
all our talking in court
mr rashid expressed his remorsefulness
he accepted responsibility and he's
ready
to do what the judge said and go back
and make people happy with his music
rasheed is ordered to self
surrender in august reporting in
downtown las vegas vanessa murphy 8 news
now